[Musique]
nous sommes en 1979 un journal allemand
le stern publié un article dans lequel
on affirme avoir trouvé le journal
intime d'adolphe hitler way le führer en
personne
sauf que ces journaux plutôt ce journal
intime il est faux
[Musique]
pour comprendre un peu ce qui s'est
passé il faut se remettre dans le
contexte des années 70 en allemagne à
l'époque l'allemagne n'est pas unique
vous avez d'un côté la rfa et de l'autre
la rd donc une parti communiste et une
partie capitaliste et démocratique un
homme
conrad couillaud va commencer à se
spécialiser dans la revente d'objets
nazis pourquoi parce que dans les années
70 il y en a beaucoup qui veulent se
rappeler cette époque là et plus encore
qui collectionne les objets de la
seconde guerre mondiale couillaud va
même aller plus loin il commence à
produire des faux faux en écriture les
fausses signatures de hauts dirigeants
comme goebbels goering et mind la fausse
signature d'adolphe hitler
aveugles ont ils fait de l'argent mais
il veut aller plus loin couillaud au
besoin d'une grande entreprise
et c'est là qu'il va commencer à rédiger
ce que vont devenir les faux journaux
intimes d'adolphe hitler il y passe
trois et après cette grande entreprise y
présente ses journaux ou journal stern
en allemagne en disant qu'il a découvert
quelque chose de neuf quelque chose qui
va révolutionner carrément la
connaissance qu'on a sur la période de
la seconde guerre mondiale en allemagne
le journal sceptique dans un premier
temps propose de faire des analyses
question de vérifier si tout cela est
vrai on compare et on réalise que c'est
un vrai
pourquoi parce que l'échantillon
d'écriture qu'on a fourni pour analyser
le journal intime et celle réalisée par
conrad couillaud ouais les fausses
signatures d'hitler c'est ce dont on
s'est servi pour croiser avec le faux
journal intime donc le journal se dit ça
y est on peut annoncer la nouvelle
arrive le grand jour on annonce au monde
entier qu'on a trouvé le journal intime
d'adolphe hitler branle bas de combat on
en parle partout dans le monde et
tranquillement on se dit qu'il faudrait
peut être analysé la chose le journal se
dit votre problème on le fait donc c'est
sûr que c'est un vrai sauf que non c'est
pas du tout le même résultat they know
cette vaste tour d
or aux jo de stuc secours qu'est ce
qu'on va trouver entre autres que le
papier sur lequel était écrit le faux
journal d'hitler date d'après 1945 que
l'écriture n'est pas conforme à ce qu'on
trouve dans les archives bref que c'est
un faux archi faux que va-t-il se passer
avec ce four journal d'adolphe hitler et
ben si vous voulez le voir aujourd'hui
on en retrouve certains exemplaires aux
archives nationales question de se
rappeler que le fonds peut servir à
faire l'histoire aussi il ya 32 ans
[Musique]